I'm Ildikó Fekete, mother of two.
I graduated as a literature teacher,
but I'm a coder now.
I was expecting my first child
when complications arose
and my doctor advised me
to stay at home for the rest of my pregnancy.
I decided to quit my job,
but I didn't want to sit at home doing nothing.
Then, my husband and I had to move for his job.
We faced a lot of new challenges
during this time.
That's when I realised I could never
go back to my old job.
It was through an internet search
that I found this opportunity
to be sponsored by Google
to study via the Udacity website.
It sounded perfect for me
and I signed up.
We learned how to build apps
for Android devices,
how to create the layout
and code in Java.
I really enjoyed the support
provided through the Udacity online course.
I have created the GreenFeet app
which can calculate our carbon footprints.
After my children were born, I noticed how
much more rubbish we were producing.
I didn't think I'd ever be able
to create my own app,
one that's connected
to protecting the environment,
one that really matters
and can impact other peoples' lives.
I think programming
gives us the opportunity to be creative.
Being a "coding mum" is difficult but amazing.
I'm confident that getting certified
through Udacity's online courses
will make it easier for me to find work
that's compatible with my life as a mum.